[Music]
around 70 million people have voted for
donald trump in 2020.
donald trump's fighting for everybody in
the world that is oppressed
around 8 million more than in 2016.
usa usa those voters watched what he'd
been up to in the white house in the
last four years
and they wanted more been great i wish
we could have four more we often hear
about one
specific type of donald trump supporter
that they live here in the midwest
and they like to carry a gun but the
reality is
this election shows donald trump's base
is far broader than that in fact exit
polls suggest
people were actively voting for donald
trump whereas joe biden voters were more
likely to be voting for the least bad
option
so let's look behind the stereotypes to
see where donald trump's support
is coming from
suburban women will you please like me
remember please please
a higher percentage of women voted for
donald trump in this election compared
to 2016 in fact more than 55 percent
of white women supported him this time
around
i have many women suburban women friends
and they were all on board for trump
he's weathered many
scandals that infamous leaked locker
room chat
the stormy daniels affair and he's faced
women's marches around the world
but for some women donald trump is still
the best option
and he wants to get rid of the corrupt
lying people in washington
and women who raise children we teach
our kids not to lie
not to be corrupt not to steal
it wasn't just white women lending
donald trump their vote
across the board more women voted
republican
[Applause]
the latino community also turned out for
donald trump
there's long been an assumption that
minority groups would vote for the
democrats but like
many things in this election those
assumptions those generalizations
were wrong coming from cuba we all know
what communism and socialism looks like
we know fake promises when somebody says
it and
joe biden is basically giving us fake
promises
although a majority of latinos did vote
for biden
an increased number went red nobody has
done more for the black
community than donald trump with the
exception
of abraham lincoln possible exception
trump
also increased the proportion of black
americans voting for him
that's despite his criticism of the
black lives matter protests which have
dominated the news agenda this year
you're not going to agree with
everything he does but i mean he's a lot
better than
joe biden for me so he's he just
recently came up with the platinum plan
i believe like four or five months ago
helping the black and brown
neighborhoods if you look at the
democratic grand cities
i mean they're tearing it up they're
turning up their own neighborhoods in
fact
it looks like his reaction to those
protests may have helped him
the people who had an unfavorable
opinion of the black lives matter
movement
85 percent voted for donald trump
and of course coronavirus has impacted
everything in this election
of the people who think the economy is
more important than coronavirus measures
a huge majority voted for trump he has
painted himself as the president of
money a businessman who can revitalize
america's economy
i like his ideas about tariffs about the
economy about trying to bring some of
the businesses back from offshore
i think he's done a good job with
economics whereas biden promised
to prioritize coronavirus yeah i don't
believe there's scientific evidence to
show that the mask will stop anybody
from getting anything and those who
thought wearing a face mask is a
personal choice
rather than a public responsibility also
donald trump voters i can tell you jesus
christ is my savior and lord
and how trump professes that is up to
him and his faith
faith is more powerful than government
and nothing
is more powerful than god finally
you also can't underestimate the power
of america's evangelical community
76 of white evangelical or born-again
christians
voted for trump they made up more than a
quarter of the people surveyed
so we're talking about a group with
significant voting power i think he
stands up
for life i think he stands up for all
people
and when you look at the values of a
category of evangelicals
you find those values within that broad
spectrum
he won their support back in 2016 but it
has decreased slightly this time round
but make no mistake donald trump's
anti-abortion stance and his
conservative
policies do really well in places like
michigan
where around a quarter of the population
are evangelical christians
he believes in god he trusts in god you
know evangelicals
trust in god and believe the bible and
the judeo-christian
view of life and that's what he
that's what he supports and believes i
am your voice and
we will make america great again and
that's what we're doing
[Applause]